when milli approached you after the
course in Riverside and said I'm so
silly I did this you saw something in
her that if the other writer said well I
don't want to take the grapes of wrath'
and and outline it well then they're
kind of they believe in this romance of
being able to write and just sort of sit
down and I'm gonna take a bottle of
scotch and a cigarette and pound away
all the things that happen to me they
love with the image of being a writer
you know it's the romance from being a
writer the struggle the torment the
agony and the ecstasy all of those
grandiose concepts that writers have
done to get bigger payment paydays you
know that's all good like I had a writer
it was a client for years dear friend
who I think we sold like 12 of his
screenplays and it took him honestly a
week to write a screenplay Wow and it
took me three years to train him never
never to admit that in it and so worried
I got him an agent and the agent was
always beating him up and saying you
can't say that you you have to you have
to say you need three months six months
or whatever you can't say you do it in a
week they won't you know we're trying to
get a million dollars for this you know
and that's the truth is you can do it in
a week but you can you know put it aside
for two months and then go back and work
on it some more and so on but because
the reality of writing is is much easier
than then the the myth of it and welker
Percy one of my favorite novelist I
wrote The Last Picture Show said perhaps
this the secret of speaking is having
something to say and that's that's what
it's all about you have a story to tell
then you can tell it's not a problem
just don't start writing it until you
know the story like you don't start
telling a joke before you know the joke
right you don't walk in with three by
five cards until a joke from a three by
five card you you know the thing by
heart and then you you tell it and it's
not the agony doesn't need to be the
agony
and when you don't have a structure that
is when you have learned the mechanics
of it like the productive two kinds of
productive writers when you learn the
mechanics you can be happy and you can
do it whenever you want to do it like
any writer who knows them will tell you
they can write on trains buses planes
they can write standing up sitting down
I had a dear friend Nancy Friedman in my
client for years who wrote on her back
for the last ten years of her life
because she couldn't sit up and she
couldn't stand up and so she wrote on
her back and she just kept writing books
and you the writing is easier if you
know what you're doing and you know
whether it's Harlan Ellison or Ray
Bradbury they'll all tell you the same
thing but when you think it's this huge
agony and it is like Virginia Woolf you
know and so on
she's never figured it out that's why
she's believed that it has to be an
agony to to be good and I don't think
Shakespeare was an agony I think he was
just dashing the stuff off as fast as he
could write because he was reading
everything that was coming from Italy
and from you know south of Europe and
stealing it like crazy redoing it
copying it you heard stories all around
and he just couldn't wait you know
before going to the pub and after going
to the pub to sit down and - it off and
he revised you know he spent a lot of
time revising we know that from the
folios but it's it's not the it's not
the living in the garret starving thing
that has to happen at all it's just
figuring out what you're doing it's a
craft you know it's a craft that has to
be learned and the art comes in there
are brilliant people who do the craft
and there are not so brilliant people
who can do the craft so there's plenty
of room for art but it's not doesn't
have to be cutting your ear off kind of
thing
you